um we are taking calls through discord
at davidpakman.com discord
we are going to go next to
um we're going to loki
from florence now that's florence where
florence could be in a lot of different
places
uh that's actually in florence kentucky
so northern kentucky area
what's going on not much i've been
watching
quite a bit now just kind of i know for
probably about the last two weeks i've
really been watching your live streams
kind of looking at a lot of different
stuff and what is going on
so i just kind of wanted to engage
something by it or at least
double check so just kind of watching
both sides in the way that this is all
advancing and progressing i know
both the republican party and the
democratic party
they have a lot of issues that they're
going to have to go through because
trump's presidency is basically invites
a lot of people
do you see there being any sort of
conflict
military and or otherwise in between the
parties
a military conflict between the
republican and democratic parties you're
saying
yes no what would that even look like i
mean who
who would be controlling the military
who would be directing the military
that's a fair point i do know that there
are several militias
at least that are uh kind of
practicing i guess i don't oh okay okay
no no but so now that's
you're asking a different question so it
sounds like you're asking is it
conceivable
that i mean i'm guessing you mean
pro-trump militias because that's
that's the but those are the militias
that there are it would would like a
pro-trump
militia go so crazy that the military is
out in the streets
fighting the pro-trump militia correct
okay that's marginally more likely i
still find
i i still think it's relatively unlikely
but that is marginally more plausible
than
than the first scenario which i think i
just misunderstood
yeah i'm kind of doing two or three
things at once but that's my
problem there sorry i i'm curious what
what else are you doing because your
phone
connection it's very interesting your
voice it almost sounds like you have a
voice modulator on
oh i've actually got my bluetooth
headphones on i'm
actually kind of cleaning dishes and
listening
uh gotcha okay maybe that it may be that
well listen let's hope it doesn't come
to that okay
definitely yeah all right and is there a
siren going off in the background
uh it could be i actually live right
down the road from a
police station at a fire station
it's been going off 24 7 around here wow
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call i appreciate it
okay sounds like sounds like he's gone
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i asked teddy stratford to
be a sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout